[Music]
PlayStation Plus has changed
no more ps3 titles normal Vita titles
unless they are crossed by with ps4
March 2019 brings us six games no it
doesn't it brings us to my first
reaction there was despair and I invite
you to say how are you feeling in the
comments below but let's have a look at
the two games that we get this month
let's start with the flagship offering
call of duty modern warfare remastered
for many of us modern warfare was the
title which brought us to the Call of
Duty franchise in 2007 it was
revolutionary the gameplay was sublime
the storytelling compelling just
thinking about the scene in the ghillie
suits brings the memories flooding back
now a decade later PS Plus invites us to
jump back in and go through captain
prices heroics with soap and gas once
again the award-winning multiplayer
returns with the fresh tune up to bring
it up to date but the question is can it
pull you away from apex legends for me
I can't wait to relive the story one
more time I don't want to go wax lyrical
here but the game is a masterpiece
especially the solo campaign the
remaster received eights and nines out
of 10 and for a game as a decade old
that's pretty impressive next up is the
witness first released in 2016 the
witness puts you in the first-person
shoes of someone trapped on a desert
island what's really impressive here is
the island is filled with puzzles which
are contextual you'll stumble across
them without realizing there's no
tutorials here there's no narrator to
keep us on track and the on-screen
prompts are almost non-existent the
island is your playground you may think
that means there's no room for story
it's here and what you may think when
the story begins is not how things stay
for long narrative twists incoming the
witness was loved by our reviewers with
plenty of perfect tense cause except for
us gamer they hated it giving it two out
of five are you gonna try it please let
me know your thoughts in the comments
below both of these games are available
from March the 5th which is a Tuesday by
the way ok so now I'd usually be talking
about ps3 and Vita games but we know
they're not here anymore
and it does not look like they're going
to be replaced any time
I am truly gutted how do you feel about
it I was certain a psvr title would be
added but alas it isn't to be on the
plus side apex legends has a few skins
and banners for you to download on your
ps4 and ps4 also receives Red Dead
Redemption online early access on
clothing emotes and weaponry over this
month the jawbone knife and over 150 new
pieces of attire to help you stand out
from the other outlaws in future videos
I'll be sure to break down all the
hidden PS plus extras but for now I bid
you farewell thanks for your time
hopefully I'll see you again soon
[Music]